[Music]
and pulls a lost soul from while a
thousand no long spoke they say that is
the great Garth Brooks offering a song
of support on Facebook last night for
the victims of the massacre in Las Vegas
like the country music community is
really rallying together on this a
shooting started while Jason Aldean's
was performing on stage he posted on
Instagram this world is becoming the
kind of place I'm afraid to raise my
children in Jan Crawford shows us a
vigil that took place last night in
Nashville the home of country music Jan
good morning
well good morning so Monday night's
vigil was a concert of sorrow and hope
and a way of raising money for victims
all with the message that Nashville will
be there for them determined and
resilient
[Music]
I will drive them Keith Urban
Vince Gill
[Music]
so you
[Music]
some of country music's biggest stars
took the stage last night in Nashville
to share their grief they're like family
it's it's the one thing about country
music that's always been at the center
of it and that is community it all took
place less than 24 hours after a gunman
opened fire on tens of thousands of
country music fans influential country
radio personality Bobby bones performed
on Saturday night for us I think the
most fun festival that we've ever played
but Monday morning on his radio show he
spoke with country star Jake Owen who
performed Sunday night about the scene
of horror I'm sad and I'm confused and
I'm angry when guitarist said the
experience changed his political views
tweeting we need gun control right now
so lot of courage but other artists left
politics aside offering messages of
unity
[Music]
so you all knew
miron Morris performed at the festival
on saturday released a song she wrote
three years ago
featuring Vince Gill as the stars showed
on Monday night
music can start the healing the fans
will persevere we'll be there to help
them and the music will be right behind
them
[Music]
miron Morris is one of the many country
music stars raising money for victims of
the attack all proceeds from her new
song will go to the charity music city
cares in the coming weeks you'll see
more of country music coming together to
raise money for people they consider
family jeff jan thank you very much how
about that song i want to be your hate I
saw you on the news today and then
bridge over troubled waters is always a
good song there was situation such a
tight-knit community